ce n'est pas facile pour les
voyageurs ils devr
- Des files d'attente
interminables, des gens
qui dorment un peu partout,
des centaines de valises
Cette famille tente de se rendre
dans les maritimes pour
des funérailles, vendredi.
Ils sonttrois de leurs valises
ont disparu.
Des centaines de personnes sont
coincées à l'aéroport depuis
des heures, dans certains cas,
annulés par manque de personnel
ont des conséquences
désastreest ici depuis 36 heure;
impossible de trouver un vol
pour retourner aux États-Unis.
- Comme on est un groupe de 19,
on dit que c'est trop compliqué.
Et puis, on a la compagnie avec
laquelle on a booké le tour,
eux, ils travaillent aussi,
mais Air Canada ne répond pas.
de se rendre à Calgary passe
le temps en s'entraînant.
et la valise de sa conjointe
est introuvable.
Cet homme cherche la valise
de sa mère depuis 10 jours
- Dans le système, on voit que
le bagage, il a ét
à Montréal, et il avait été
auparavant envoyé en Allemagne.
finale, donc depuis le 18,
j'attends.
urs voyageurs déplorent
le manque de communication
et de coordinationagnies aérien.
Pour reprendre le contrôlede las
au cours des prochains jours
seront a
PHILIPPE, PDG
Aéroports de Montréal
- Il faut faire le choixr des
destinations ou de mettre les
gens dans une situation qui est
insupportable. Donc, je crois
la bonne chose.
- Reste à voir si
L'objectif est de retrouverun cs
aéroports d'ici la mi-juillet.
Ici Mar Radio-C Radio-C Radio-n